Okay. So, that Alex Neville guy who did
the video on like Steven Crowder or
something, was it Steven Crow? I don't
know. He did on some Daily Wire or other
similar person. Um, and you did the
legal mindset video. Just did a video on
uh Destiny and Dan Sortman. So, we're
going to take a look.
>> So, would you say that you wield your
audience more like a shield [music] than
like a sword?
>> I mean, I try to in that sense, but I
wield them like a sword as well for
things that I believe in. streamer
Destiny is saying that it's justifiable
to attack and kill me in real life.
>> Hassan was terrified of the terror in
Hassan's eyes.
>> Culture war.
Culture war [music] never changes.
In the year 2025,
every community online is at war with
each other.
>> When the war comes to me, I have no
[music] choice but to defend myself.
I'm being invaded by a bunch of [__]
commies.
Let's go to war, guys.
This lame culture war. I am the
strongest soldier.
>> Alex Noel is the strongest Hanabi head.
This is the strongest Hanabi soldier.
>> A warrior sent back [music] through time
to stop judgment day from happening.
But it's getting closer every day.
Behind the constant fighting, there's
[music] one entity pulling all the
strings. Stoking the flames,
the flames of war.
One terrible force dead.
>> At least it's not a another content cop
or some [__] like that. You know, I get
take what you can get really
>> on destroying everything and everyone
that dares to criticize it. That one
force can only be reckoned with if you
have two unbeatable weapons.
It's debate.
>> Yeah, it's it's not Rowan. Yep. True.
Oh, it is a content cop thing.
It is a content thing. It is a It is a
content cop thing. Yeah. Boo. For real.
Let's just stop this. Yeah. Let's stop
this. Let's stop any content cop spins.
Any video vigilante. I think that's
Gokari's one, right?
any um
what's uh what's the one that we watched
the other night? Idiot influencers.
We need to stop this. Just period. Draw
a line under it.
It's got to end. Yeah, but this should
be like come up with something else.
Like this is fine. This is like this is
like kind of lame, but it's like lame in
a way where it's I mean you're at least
doing something, you know? But then
following up with like a content cop
spin that just took any any wind that
was in the sales before that has been
just totally taken out of it by the by
the content cop spin title.
[music]
Content cop spin-off [laughter] must go
so hard if your name is child logic.
Dude, Shelby, you'll start saying
something about about Ch like that and
then like a week later, Ch will spend
like three streams going like, "See,
see, I'm not like that, am I? I'm not
like that, am I?" [laughter]
He What's he doing with the other? It
was with AI. He was like, "Look at some
AI shit." He's like, "Oh, yeah, but I
like AI, don't I?" Oh, yeah. But I love
AI, don't I? Ch loves AI.
All right, here we go. Debating someone
like Destiny isn't easy.
>> How many miles of you?
>> Not half as many as you, sir.
>> Your mic's not on.
>> Destiny is basically the liberal version
of Ben Shapiro. So, when he does
actually debate people, it's usually
meant to farm clips for his multiple
social media channels.
>> This is the legend Destiny over here,
everybody. You get a chance to debate
him one-on-one. So if anybody else wants
to come up and debate and
>> you're choosing to do this now after
Charlie Kirk was doing it for 16 years
or however many years and that's why
you're here trying to imitate the exact
same thing. I'm not trying I would never
be so low that I would imitate such a
loser like Charlie Kirk. Number one.
Okay. Number two. Okay. I've been doing
these events for
>> Charlie.
Huh?
But you're doing literally the
thing he was doing and this tour that
you're on was set up to follow him
around doing the same thing as him.
>> What do you mean?
>> You're choosing to do this now after
Charlie Kirk was doing it for 16 years
or however many years. And that's why
you're here trying to imitate the exact
same thing. I'm not trying to I would
never be so low that I would imitate
such a loser like Charlie Kirk. Number
one. Okay. Number two.
>> Oh, sorry. He's imitating Steven Crowder
but following Charlie Kirk. Okay, that
must be it. I've been doing these events
for
>> Charlie had the balls to talk against
Israel.
>> So if I ever wanted to face
[laughter]
>> I didn't clip my holy [__]
>> Okay. I've been doing these events for
>> Charlie Kirk had the balls to talk
against Israel.
>> So if I ever wanted to face Destiny in
an epic debate of facts and logic, I had
to get him in a private call where he
couldn't showboat to his audience.
>> I even like meme set him up. I was like,
"Watch this audience.
>> How are you lying about this?
>> Shut up, Destiny. Shut up. [__] You're
so You're so shameless, dude.
>> Have had enough WITH YOUR STUPID DOG.
>> Who is the video? Who is Hey, who is the
guy?
>> I can't do it.
>> Who is the guy? Who is the guy in the
top middle? Who is the Ron? Who is that
guy? What's that video of? Who is that?
[music]
>> Did he walk away? But Destiny doesn't
just get on a private call with so
unless I wanted to pretend to be a
teenage girl. The next best thing was to
go through his right-hand man, Dan
Saltman. Could you push Destiny a little
bit to talk to me?
>> I'll tell him that the interview with
you went okay. Uh I I mean, he's not
really worried about people backstabbing
him because he his community is [__]
insane. Like I I I don't know if you
have you ever gone through [__] with a
community coming after you before? If
you know that level of insanity, you
know that like of the communities that
are like most known for being [__]
insane, everyone says like DGG is the
worst. I don't think it's the case, but
like I don't think Destiny is
particularly worried about people
backstabbing him because, you know,
nobody wants that [__] heat. Yeah. Uh
anyways, but I I'll what I'll do is I'll
um
>> I'll uh I'll message Destiny. I'm just
saying I did an interview uh with you
about Hassan. Um, he's a Jewish guy. He
mentioned he reached out to you and say
that the interview with you.
>> No way. Dan is so [__]
transparent, man.
This guy legit has ingroup bias. This
guy is like legit is so [__]
you know, he literally accepted this
interview because this guy told him he
was [__] Jewish, bro. like [laughter]
[snorts]
>> reached out to him. Did Did like did you
guys know that I like
>> we uh we we haven't talked uh very much
cuz he's just going through some crazy
[__] right now.
>> So, finally everything was set up for me
to talk to Destiny. But first, he had to
reschedu on me five different times and
then make a cringe mama joke to assert
dominance before he could join the call.
>> Hello.
>> Oh, hey. What's up? Hold on. One sec.
There he is.
>> Okay, I'm here. I'm real. How's it
going?
>> It's going good. I appreciate you doing
this. I'll jump right in. I won't waste
your time.
Destiny has been a controversial figure
on the internet for a long time now. But
recently, it feels like things are
starting to reach their peak. not only
for Destiny, but for the long-term hate
campaign he's been running against.
Three-time winner of antagonist of the
year, Hassan [__] And the Destiny
Award for antagonist of the year is
>> Hassan [__]
>> Wow.
>> Peace.
>> Good job, Hass fighting hard for that
rank one spot.
>> Destiny's Community where he is calling
for my death. At what point do we stop?
At what point do people in his orbit
say, "Hey man, I think you've gone too
far."
>> Since both of their permanent bands on
the live streaming platform Twitch,
Destiny along with his podcast co-host
Dan Saltman have intensified their
campaign to deplatform or cancel Hassan
[__] by any means necessary.
>> Hassan lost millions of dollars because
of me. This Jew cost Hassan millions of
dollars a year, guaranteed. Tell me how
if I am I wrong or am I right? Cuz he
probably right. Yeah.
>> Yeah. There you go. There. Daddy is
saying it's right for you. All right,
chat. Uh that's it. And there's nothing
that Dan is so lame, man. I love him. I
love him, but he's just so lame that he
just like he literally doesn't have any
belief that's actually motivating him.
It is literally just wanting to feel
like this like midlife crisis like
riding on top of a hate wave online. He
like he just likes that feeling of being
the the shot caller being able to take
people out
and he just sits there on on this show
and he's like Destiny tell your a tell
your audience I'm doing a good job. Tell
your audience I'm [__] owning his own
bro.
really man can do about it except take
it like my [__] that he is. You can't
destroy a leftist as a centrist or a
liberal. You can only destroy them if
you're a slightly slightly different
more extreme leftist. Then you create
this division, you know, Hassan and Dan
Clancy, you know, being the dude that
they can't destroy and they're saying
you can't destroy him to me. And it's
like, I know, but this person can. And
it's like slightly different leftist.
Sorry, a little rambling there, but I
[music] just wanted to drive the point
home to you that um these people's
success is not based around their
politics. And I know that sounds stupid.
It's based around the culture and the
identity and um the the the communities
that they foster and develop. My
community will hit us some [music]
because we have severe epistemic
differences. Like our approach to how we
do, you know, research or truth or with
the other political is quite different.
>> Talk to me about how you gather
information versus how he does.
Um, I feel like when I go to Hassan's
stream, there's a lot of people now
where you basically just kind of go for
like marching orders, like what do
progressives think right now? What do
tankies think right now? What do
whatever. I mean, I feel like that's the
majority of media today. Um, [music] I
mean, there's like pros and cons to it,
but for better or for worse, I don't
really cleanly map on to any political
ideology. So, I'm kind of free of the
pressure of having to [music] agree with
one side. Trump in terms of
>> except except he's just like totally in
line with like moderate pro-Israel dams
on like everything
>> his policies was not really that
radical.
>> Not actually at all.
>> You agree in terms of policy he wasn't
he wasn't really that much different
than than even his even his Democrat
predecessors.
>> Sure.
>> Your your community's been at war with
Hassan, especially when it comes to like
Reddit.
Yeah, kind of.
>> What is your role in that in terms of
like are you okay with that? Would you
rather them not be at war or is it
better for the overall continuing of the
thing that you're building to have a
community that is galvanized in this
way? [music]
>> I mean, it really depends on what you
mean by at war. Like, I think it's good
for us to, you know, further our beliefs
and ideas online. And I think it's good
to argue about things, especially when
we think somebody else is being
untruthful. I'm a tit fortat guy. If you
want to roll in the mud, I'll gladly
roll in the mud with you. Um, I have a
lot of experience doing it, a big
history doing it, and I have no problem
doing it.
>> Destiny and Dan Saltman have waged a
fullscale information war, wielding
their communities and resources to
spread their anti-Hassan message across
the internet.
>> Is Hassan going to create some people
that are going to be terrorists or or,
you know, I don't know how you would do
it. are the I think there's probably a
very good chance that there will be some
shootings that get attributed to, you
know, Hassan watchers. I think we
already have some um personally, but um
>> yeah, which ones?
Which ones, Dan? Which ones? I'd love to
know. I would love to know which
shootings.
>> Which ones? You know, [music]
>> I would say uh the El Elias Rodri
Rodriguez guy who did the um
>> dude, he's seriously saying the embassy
shooting.
The embassy is that that's the one,
right?
>> The two shootings. Uh the Israeli um
>> Yeah, the embassy the not the embassy
shooting, but you know what I mean. The
embassy workers. They were embassy
workers.
>> Dude, [laughter]
what is the evidence he was fan?
staffer. I've shared the information I
have with that um with the relevant
people. So,
>> are you, you know, working alongside Dan
a lot with this stuff or what's your
kind of perspective on the feeding the
trolls of it all?
>> Um Dan typically does his own thing. Uh
for feeding
>> it was just Twitch account and similar
politics, right? They couldn't find
anything that actually linked otherwise
they would have been shouting from the
rooftops, but there wasn't actually any
definitive link.
>> The trolls, it really just depends. Like
you don't want to get into the personal
stuff too much cuz if you do then then
all the fights become personal.
>> What a [__] loser. God, he's such a
Neanderthal [__] He's such a slime [__]
piece of [__]
>> He's like skitso or not skitso. He's
like a psychopath. [music]
>> Hassan is the most uh deviant person I
know.
>> That's [__] Hold on. Let me do my say
your [__] whatever the [__]
stupid [__] you were about to say.
Completely undermine exact
>> saying to Destiny. So crazy.
It's just so [__] obscene, man. It's
so [__] obscene. [laughter]
>> What I was saying, sorry.
>> Destiny in this way reminds me a lot of
another guy who I spoke to once on this
channel. But did OJ do it?
>> You know, um maybe Nazi once asked me
that question and he was prime minister
and I said, "Does Israel have nuclear
weapons?" And he said, "Allan, you know,
I can't tell you that. Lawyers have
confidences and we can't we can't
disclose those confidences just as prime
ministers of Israel have confidences.
>> Destiny and Dersuits have a lot in
common and it's not just their
proclivities for young girls or the
state of Israel. They've both made
careers out of framing criticism as
persecution while also thriving on
confrontations for their personal
branding.
>> You're engaging in bigotry. Look, I
fought against apartheid. [music] I was
part of the legal team for Nelson
Mandela. Kind of kind of cooking here.
He's kind of cooking here.
>> How dare you call Israel an aparttheid
state? Has Israel been committing a
genocide?
>> I wouldn't say so, but
>> no.
>> Not yet.
>> Not yet. Really?
>> Yep. Really? Yep.
>> Also, like Duritz, Destiny's love of
public confrontations and unwillingness
to back down from a fight would find him
entrenched in a legal battle related to
allegations of
>> streamer. destiny may be legally trapped
as we look at this new scandal and
>> see anyone else I would start seething
at the inclusion of legal mindset but I
I know Alex Neville
has made a video on legal mindset so I'm
like okay it's fine this is just
included this is just here and I know I
know he's above using this as if this
guy's smart thank you for the raid moral
thank you
>> trenched in a legal battle related to
allegations of
>> streamer Destiny may be legally ly
trapped as we look [music] at this new
scandal and we're turning to what may be
criminal charges. A few days ago, a
Reddit post showed that the girl Destiny
shared Pixie's nudes with was seemingly
confirmed to be 17 years old due to her
getting docked. There is almost a 0%
chance that she was not 17 during that
time.
>> These allegations, however serious,
don't seem to actually phase Destiny's
controversy adult brain. Talk to me
about like that
the day that like everything kind of
blew up on Twitter and and how you felt
and your reaction to that
>> everything which everything
>> like all when everyone started calling
you a pett.
>> Um at this point I'm basically I'm used
to everything so it is what it is. I
know if I just keep streaming and I do
my thing generally everything goes away
after a week or two. Yeah.
Even more so than Destiny, Dan Saltman
has spent an insane amount of time,
money, and whatever other resources or
connections he [music] has to try to
destroy Hassan [__] And he says he's
doing it all because he's trying to stop
anti-semitism.
>> I already have my my money, right? I I
don't have to stream. I don't have to go
and uh do anything on that front. like
I'm here and I can be as resourceful and
impactful as I want to be to try and
make the [music] world uh a better place
through hopefully uh just neoliberal uh
type of of
>> um pressure and show the world reality
of what it is.
>> All right, first off, this website, just
to be clear, is not owned or operated by
Twitch. And this site is uh well, you
know, you don't have to read all that,
but it's there.
>> What's a gripe site? Don't worry about
it.
>> This is uh Destiny's podcast co-host,
Orbiter, who spends every wagon moment
[laughter] actively trying to get me
deplatformed. I realize that I don't
have nearly the resources of what the,
you know, the ADL or anyone else has.
The hatred.tv site is just another kind
of piece in that puzzle. The creation of
these sites allows
their impact [music] to reach a lot more
people in a lot more uh
understandable way. All of a sudden,
it's not like a, you know, an
anti-semitism issue. Now it's just a
like why why does Twitch as a company
push Hassan so high and protect him so
much?
>> Dan Saltman's aggressive Zionism along
with his regressive beliefs about free
speech on the internet have made him a
powerful and outspoken ally for destiny
in the war against Hassan [__]
>> When I go through hatred.tv, TV, right?
I
>> the I look at like the each glowing dot
in the field,
>> you know, there's nothing in this video
yet that is throwing up crazy red flags.
Like no claim is has thrown up any crazy
red flags
>> represents 100 messages in Hassan's
chat. And I click on one and uh a lot of
the stuff is like kill all Zionist pigs.
Uh Israel already killed all of its own
[__] citizens. that uh you know uh
I just trying to trying to read one for
example
is is people saying kill all Zionists in
Hassan's [music] chat in your mind a dog
whistle for you know kill all Jews.
>> Um yes for the most part. Yeah. Um I I I
would almost absolutely usually
>> say that to be the case. I don't I think
it's going to be incredibly rare that it
wouldn't be the case. People like to
call me like a alternate ultra Zionist
genocidal maniac and uh in my mind uh I
think the Jews should have gotten half
of Germany. I think that would have been
the the fair thing to have in that
situation. So it's just it, you know,
but these people for their entire life
have been told that Jews are evil um and
that they want to destroy you and if you
kill
>> I love Dan. I love Dan. [laughter]
I love Dan, bro. He is just such a Jew.
Oh my god.
>> Would have been the the fair thing to
have in that situation. So, it's just
it, you know, but these people for their
entire life,
>> you you killed this guy, give me half
your country, go
you think that's fair, [__] [laughter]
>> told that Jews are evil. um and that
they want to destroy you and if you kill
one of them you're going to you're going
to um you know I don't know all the
religious terms but it's crazy and to in
to com combat that level of
indoctrination there has to be a massive
influx of um resources into that area
there needs to be a McDonald's on every
corno
it's just like insane to suggest that
the Jews should have gotten half of
Germany to be honest like a lot of the
Holocaust was like expanding through
Poland and killing like Polish Jews as
well Like it's not about like they
wouldn't want the neighboring country to
Germany again.
They [laughter] want the neighboring
country to Germany again. That's
suicidal
corner and everyone there needs to be
driving a Ferrari. And it and I know it
sounds stupid, but it's only at that
point that these people are are uh that
the residents of of of Gaza and the West
Bank are going to be like maybe, you
know, let's focus on something besides
killing Jews cuz life right now is
pretty awesome.
>> When Dan Salman isn't podcasting with a
sex pest or obsessing over Hassan [__]
he's running his company redact.dev,
an app that's supposed to help you
delete your messages that's designed
about as well as his anti-Hassan
websites. So, Redact as a company came
to be um a few years ago.
>> Redact is a fine service. No. What's
wrong with Redact?
>> Redact has been based around the idea of
letting you manage data that you
yourself have created. If you ever feel
like pushing it, let me know. And um you
know, we have uh an affiliate program
that I can can get you in.
>> But don't let the cluttered interface
>> This guy is unreal. This guy is [__]
unreal, man.
He is
just
shameless.
He literally tries to get everyone
on the Redact affiliate program. It's
crazy.
>> You yourself have created.
>> If you ever feel like pushing it, let me
know. And um you know, we have an
affiliate program.
>> I don't think that happened.
>> Can get you in that Rita's gone over
extensively. I don't believe that's the
case. the cluttered interface or the
fact that if you use his app it will
disable your Discord account be reasons
that you never use a piece of technology
designed by Dan Saltman because he also
created Tiny Chat, one of the first
tools that would use to video chat with
teenage girls on the internet.
>> I don't know if you know this about me
but you know a long time ago uh I
created the first like Twitch type
website that there was. We were bigger
than Skype at one point. Uh it was
called Tiny Chat. It's called Tiny Chat
and it's the latest craze on the
internet. Users need a Facebook, MySpace
or Twitter account to access the site.
And once they do, they are instantly
connected to millions of people by
webcam.
>> Look what he's doing.
>> Some of the chats are fun, just like
Tiny Chat advertises.
But others show people and in many
instances minors. We even found
teenagers themselves to other teens.
>> He wants everyone to see that
>> with the budget.
>> So, my understanding is
I don't quite know what was censored
here, but I don't think it's about like
CP or anything. I I'm pretty sure
they're talking about like smoking weed
and [__] like that on on webcam
in this in this segment. However,
it absolutely is the case that there was
untoward stuff happening on tiny chat
>> and in many instances minors. We even
found teenagers themselves to other
teens.
>> He wants everyone funded this website.
Yeah.
>> To see that
>> with the budget cuts everywhere. I
police departments nowhere is going to
have any sort of resources available to
>> the way these were exposed. I saw the
pull of teens exposed each other. Okay.
even remotely
go after something like that.
>> So all all those things said like um
>> someone said there was
that smoking weed was sensed or
something.
>> We ran that company very successfully.
We built it to um you know a huge amount
of users. So I do feel uh you know very
knowledgeable.
>> Do you feel responsible somewhat for
like creating a monster in that way?
>> Uh no I don't I don't I don't feel
responsible. There was we just, you
know, did group video chat and then, you
know, people took it to a level that
>> Well, let's just let's just go watch it.
What's uh what is this,
>> dude? I tried to look for I just found
like a 13year-old video of of someone
recording their screen with a camera.
>> Hey guys. And um I am on Tiny Chat
>> and people are saying hi.
>> So yeah, I'm on Leah's Tiny Chat. I
don't know if I already said that. Okay,
>> dude.
So yeah, this was uh this was Dan's app.
This was Dan's app. Types of people
using Dan's app. [laughter]
[snorts] Where's uh where's this news
report that he'sing?
Dude, what the fur from Tiny Chat? What?
Huh?
This is vintage [__] man.
Okay, [laughter]
>> because of that, that's why we have to
live in saying,
>> "Dude,
crazy stuff comes up. Start searching
tiny chat on YouTube." It turns out I
wanted the news report, but there's so
much other insane [__] here. chat
advertises,
but others show people and in many
instances minor found teenagers.
>> Uh, wait, wait, wait. A ABC7
or some [__] right? This channel ABC7
each. No, it's all just more of the the
videos like this.
It's the children's videos like the ones
that we were
finding just then. Whatever I search,
it's still coming up with
like 110 view videos from
15 years ago.
Paris Jackson on Tiny Chat. Lavoon's
friend Paris Jackson. Hassan's ex Paris
Jackson. [laughter]
What? Dude, what the [__] dude?
themselves to other teens.
>> He wants everyone to see that
>> with the budget cuts everywhere. I
police departments nowhere is going to
have any sort of resources available to
even remotely
go after something like that.
>> So all all those things said like um you
know we ran that company very
successfully. We built it to um you know
a huge amount of users. So I do feel uh
you know very knowledgeable. Uh
>> do you feel responsible somewhat for
like creating a monster in that way?
>> Uh no I I don't I don't feel
responsible. There was all we just you
know did group video chat and then you
know people took it to a level that was
way more uh frisky afterwards. You had
chat roulette that came afterwards and
that kind of gave everything a really
bad name.
>> Beyond all of the shoddy tech and
targeted websites, Dan Saltman's big
>> tiny chat was it was chat roulette that
started giving stuff a bad name. Wait,
this is a Sid just spotted this in the
Tiny Chat news segment.
Just the the [__] computer wallpaper
in the background. Spider-Man 3 desktop
wallpaper in the background. So [__]
base, dude. Holy.
So [__] awesome.
Real ass. Own this computer. You can
tell.
>> We even found teenagers exposing
themselves to other teens. And when
Channel 7 showed the site to Michigan
State Police Sergeant William Lasbinsky,
it was the first time he had seen it
>> with the W. There we go. biggest weapon
is his ability to constantly add his own
ved perspective to the narrative.
>> Why I do this is I think because I I
can. After October 7th, I was in a very
um I I felt strange. I
>> They said smoking weed before that.
Apparently, it says both. It says both.
>> Can I do something to stop this? And and
I I felt like
>> [music]
>> um I could I felt like, you know, the
success that I've done with my
businesses that I should be able to use
that to
>> [music]
>> um find out what pressure points I can
push to make a positive change. I wish I
did this thing. I wish I spent more time
with my kids. It's always all these
things I wish that I did. And I realized
at the point like, you know, [__] it.
This is going to be one of those things
I think that I'm going to regret later
on in life is that like I had the
opportunity to make an impact and
hopefully counter [music]
this narrative that like all Jews are
[__] evil. The ability to counter
that um was was worthwhile. Dance
Saltman's unwillingness to get a hobby
or go spend some time with his kids
would be astonishing to most people, but
that's the way things go during the
Culture War. Veteran debate lords like
Destiny can't spend time with their kids
when there's a war going on. Even if his
own son falls victim to the same online
extremism that Destiny claims to fight
against.
>> You've said that you were a Nazi. You've
said that you endorse Adolf Hitler.
>> Um and and look, these are these are
pretty morally horrible views in my
view. The
>> book I'm reading right now, ironically,
is mine come. I'm trying to understand
psychology of Hitler. I do want to ask
you about like how your son's been
radicalized because I've seen a lot of
his posts and interviews about, you
know, his beliefs on on, you know,
Hitler and stuff.
>> It's kind of annoying cuz I said a lot
of crazy stuff when I was a kid. I mean,
I imagine right now he's going through
his whole thing. There's a lot of people
online that are very motivated and
invested in trying to have him, you
know, turn out one way or another.
Hassan and everybody else likes to talk
about him, but I mean, like, I chat with
him. He's 14. if he still believes this
when he's, you know, 16, [music]
probably going to be pretty worried.
But, man, people go through phases and
I'm not going to sit here and try to
audit 14-year-old's [music] beliefs to
make sure that they're perfectly in
alignment with my, you know, democratic
liberal beliefs. You people grow. As
long as he doesn't do anything that
>> gets them kicked out of school, then
it'll be okay. Hopefully.
>> Destiny claims that his community is
immune from extremes
and Star Wars shirt, man. It's never
been more over.
>> Thank you for the $5. Thank you.
You know it's a Terminator shirt, right?
>> Ability to tell which people are making
racist jokes and which people are
actually racist. You should probably
call it a bend my pretty obvious we
don't hate Jews. Like sometimes the son
will call me or my community
anti-semitic cuz there are some
anti-semitic jokes that I I make. I
think there's a lot of I think there's a
lot of funny jokes that can be racist or
sexist or whatever. But like it's pretty
obvious that my community is not like
community. Whereas a son will never make
those kinds of jokes per se, but his
community buys into a lot of the like um
>> Jimmy isn't as you should know [snorts]
>> like Zionist occupied government. You
see like young Turks and everything now
are going hardcore. I think that kind of
anti-semitis is a lot more insidious and
damaging than just you know idiots
telling jokes. Even if those people are
like a little bit hateful. What Destiny
doesn't want to admit, or maybe just
doesn't realize, is that after years of
constant controversy, he's conditioned
his community to carry out his bidding
and defend his actions, no matter how
reprehensible the crime.
>> I should just make like a guideline for
all this, right? Always deny the initial
thing, say there's no context, or just
don't address it at all. Say the other
side is lying. Make up some [__]
allegation. Get everybody in your orbit
to carry the message. All of your
[__] sickopantic fans will carry the
exact same message. And then if there's
anybody ostensively that's on your side
um or there's anybody that uh is even
rolling on your side then you just
harass the [__] out of them until they
acquies until they give into it to all
the harassment and they have to change
their opinion. At a certain point, it
comes down to people wielding their
audience as a weapon or as a shield from
controversy or from, you know, attacks
by other creators because it's something
that's so common and it's something that
even I contribute to as someone who's
made a fair amount of videos that like
cover controversy.
>> Um, I mean, what I mean, what what about
it? I mean, people, it's just the nature
of crowds anywhere, right? Countries do
it. Uh, activist groups do it. Tan does
it. They They're just taking notes from
him, right? Like the pe the audience
will follow the the streamer in terms of
how they do it. I think the other day,
what did he was like? He called me like
sex pestin mlestin. So like four
nicknames in a row.
>> Calling you destits. You like Israel so
much. You'd be more Alan Destitz than uh
Sex Destiny.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Okay.
>> Destiny's main tactic has been to focus
everybody's negative attention onto
Hassan [__] and away from his own
repeated bad behaviors. and it's
actually working.
>> When a song goes out and he does
podcasts, he just gets very little uh
[music] I guess like traction outside of
Twitch, but but when I go my my poll
will be five times greater sometimes.
And I think that kind of bothers him.
And I think he realized that. So, he's
kind of been more intentional about
trying to reach out at least for
mainstream media pieces, although I
don't think he's going to find the
success he's looking for there either.
>> He does get institutional support.
Hassan does have interactions with these
people. Uh, and that's because, um,
currently they don't look far enough
into seeing how much of a enemy of the
Democrats Hassan [__] is. Um, and I
hope that that can change in the future.
>> The goal is to maximize, for instance,
um, attention and and eyes on him and
impressions as much as possible. It's
all about just eyes on it's all about
attention and impressions.
>> Since the beginning of 2025, when the
revenge porn allegations first dropped,
there have been 10 major media articles
about Destiny's case. When Hassan's dog
slipped on her canvas bed and yelped,
Destiny and Dan Saltman worked
tirelessly to spread the narrative that
Hassan [__] was
>> okay.
I haven't looked into it all. I don't
100% know the truth. I think Assan
probably did shock his dog, but hey, you
know, whatever, man. I I don't care.
>> Shocking his dog with an e-collar to
keep it in place during his live stream.
stupid. I also like how the dog put his
foot on something, whatever that means.
Um, but Hassan doesn't care about it.
He's not interested in it. He has no
idea what it was. This is apparently the
first time this has ever happened,
right? Like I don't think has the dog
ever
>> Maybe that maybe has Ka tried learning
to um learn to do something cool
like this?
[music]
>> [singing]
>> Maybe he wouldn't get like shocked.
[music]
>> The post this video was the start of the
American century of humiliation before.
So like what? There's so many
indications that he's lying. There's so
many He's like so obviously lying. It's
so cringe.
>> Dude, this dog is is causing this guy so
much [__] problem. He's
>> more than anything else.
>> More than anything I've done, which is,
you know, sad, but also like, you know,
it is what it is. I learned from them
because I I learned from them because
[music] they spent so much time [__]
over Ethan Klein with saying his dog was
fed cheese and I was just like, you know
what,
that's a good strategy. Let's [__] do
that [__]
>> That accusation led to over 25 major
media articles covering the Hassan [__]
dog collar drama. Destiny himself has
made over 300 videos talking about
Hassan [music] on his YouTube channel,
and that's not even including live
streams.
>> Give me the Hassan clip. I need my hater
clips ready.
>> Hassan bad, but unironically, but I'm
worse.
>> It's not fair to chastise all of America
for slavery because only 2% of Americans
own slaves. Like, Hassan would have been
part of that 2%. [music] Like, that's
the kind of person insane to me. Jesus.
>> Okay. Am I crazy or did his mom not say
in like a stream once basically imply
that they had like a plantation with
slaves back in Cuba? God, I hate this
guy. If you're a trans person and you
take any like direction from Hassan,
you're actually such a loser. When I was
living in LA, me and Hassan actually
played a game of horse and I destroyed
him. And it was actually from that
moment onwards that our relationship
started to deteriorate. Fighting against
Hassan [__] and his community of
radical socialists has become the main
goal not just of Destiny and Dan
Saltman, but tons of other creators on
the internet.
>> There's a few people in there that it's
like this battle that's going on, if you
will. I guess you could say asminold is
in there. Techone is in there. There's
always like large communities that are
kind of like controlling the direction.
Um, my community is a large one. XQC's
is decently big. Asmin Golds is a large
one. And then Hans is kind of there. Um,
the dynamic right now is Asthma Gold,
XQC, and my community all hate Hassan.
Uh, so if I say anything negative in
that direction, it'll get a lot of
traction, but not necessarily because
they like me, just because they hate
Hassan. Anytime we see a Hassan [__]
post, we try to post really mean and
rude stuff about him so he cries about
on stream. Um, yeah, it's a hugely
coordinated effort. I think I spend
probably over $200,000 a month on bots
and Nazis to go and spam bad stuff about
Hassan [__]
>> Okay, good. Okay, so me and you do the
same thing. Awesome. I do that on GE.
>> Yeah. Uh I don't I don't have as much
money as you said. $200,000 a little bit
out of my price range.
>> The concept of a large group of people
being against capitalism is rightfully
scary to large creators online who are
held up by that same capitalist system.
To those creators, fear-mongering with
red scare politics and galvanizing your
base to go after the tankies probably
seems like a very good content strategy.
But in actuality, it's just another
method in the culture war playbook.
Drama is interesting. I mean, the the
history of the world is is drama. What's
your favorite hobby?
>> Me?
>> Yeah.
>> Um, I have a standard poodle and I uh
like video editing.
>> You have a standard poodle like a dog?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. I don't know anything about
poodles, so I can't make any analogy
there, but I've been streaming for 16
years and fighting and arguing with
people and confrontation is kind of I
guess partial school that I do is kind
of fun for me.
Building your online community up by
going to war with other creators and
their communities is something that's
incredibly commonplace these days.
There's a whole news politics and
entertainment system in place ready to
be misused and exploited by guys like
Destiny to stop progressive ideas from
actually breaking through. But things
are starting to change. Many are
starting to get fed up with politicians
failure to address the labor,
healthcare, and cost of living crisis in
America. Oh my god. Lefty politics
outro. No. Stop.
>> Of those raging issues. Most of the
discourse is clouded by the culture war.
>> In any case, that's where we're at in
our [music] culture. That's where we're
at in the uh realm of commentary. And
these guys are way too predisposed with
silliness as opposed to [music] solving
any of the crises that are personally
responsible for. And [music] the worst
part about it is that for many
Americans, they're fine with that. They
like it. They're like, "No, this is
great. This is awesome." Yeah. No, keep
me invested in this silly.
>> Yeah. I guess the video was okay.
How's it doing
>> to film yourself on a camera? I
>> So would you.
>> Not great.
It was okay. If you quit your sweeping,
what is there a bit at the end? There's
not. What it was? Yeah, that's like a
six or seven out of 10. It wasn't like
amazing. was okay.